hello citizens of the rejection it's me Tara
Erickson a long time my friends say your name
Andrew it is I oh he said it interesting but
he didn't give his last name I don't remember
oh my goodness we watch make one together and
now we're gonna watch make two if you haven't
seen me and this guy watch make one you should
go back you should watch it it's on this channel
now listen up you're gonna leave a like right
you're gonna get on the computer go do some
comment do you say how cool we are and also don't
forget to subscribe and when you do you'll bring
was a different one did you like it I loved it
everything I switched it up full length reaction
and watch long is on the patreon so you guys
need to become patrons if you're not already
okay because you can sync up with your full copy
what's the whole thing with me and him the whole
entire thing you sit there popcorn candy me and
him talking about make two megalodons and 18 abs
two also Greg and John cover several
shows over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watchalogs included
now are you ready for a Megalodon because
I'm getting Juiced up I'm already Juiced up
I'm so excited okay megalodons here we go
[Music]
foreign [Music]
65 million years ago
ah such as nature works yeah bye bye little
bug and what's gonna eat that uh oh yeah
cool Tyrannosaurus
Tyrannosaurus oh my God [Music]
are they like we can take you to your ex
or what no okay they turned around that's
not a good sign oh boy please let this uh
shark jump right if the shark eats him alive
like what y'all running from I know I'm scared
[Music]
oh my God yes I am on board I was a nice tone
Setter that was awesome but it doesn't matter
we got Jason Statham again that shark still
doesn't stand a chance it doesn't matter if
it can take out Tyrannosaurus Rex no it
doesn't we got 18 ABS he's got so many
much what's the most amount you can do um 0.5
12. really I can't go past 12 as of right now
I'm not gonna lie I've never I don't think I've
tried to do a pull up I'll have to get on that
what is going on in here oh cool
said explosive Jill I don't know
I just I just know that word from
the Arkham games thank you Batman
where is he what oh awesome in a shipping yard on
a boat why is this man anywhere near water anymore
he's like dude I took down megalodons I ain't
afraid of the water that's probably his job
now he's like come on now you people pay me
to be out here because I'm awesome with Megas
oh he snuck aboard okay oh Jason Statham looks
older but he's still hot AF I just watched him
uh in Snatch obviously he's way younger but
he's always been such a badass yeah alcohol
I would release the parrot do it offer him a
cracker it worked in Home Alone three ah well done
I'm here from the home office
that's funny there's no line that's going
to beat that no oh ah what's going on oh
okay all right what are these people
doing on this boat damn I mean we saw
them throwing what looked like oil
into the wall oh is that I missed it
I think uh maybe I saw it but I didn't
register because you guys know how I am
damn now cool yeah
yeah you get them
that stair jump was awesome
[Music]
into the ocean no you're all under arrest
Eagle dumping of radioactive material there you go
you want to see the word it's right in my pocket
does he have a thing yeah he
has a thing in his backpack
right you're 200 miles I'm sure so enjoy your swim
oh nice is that Cliff Curtis yeah cool it's like
a green James Bond James Bond yeah it is awesome
as we mentioned earlier Dark Knight esque with
the Escape oh yeah it'd be awesome Define awesome
that's awesome also I feel like he'd get
in there and slam his head as they take
off right into a wall I don't know why to see how
it knocked out but they're not gonna show us yeah
oh my God damn okay 21 increasing power
only 21 that guy's breaking cement is
that really the little girl from the
first one yeah it got a little older
so obviously that's her brother from
uh okay because he said favorite niece
the guy looked familiar to you no I don't like him
you don't like anyone I like you that's because I
save your life all the time I buy your beers and
I back you up in bar fights I would like him too
yeah can you be my best friend right please give
a warm welcome to the director of The Institute
oh from the last movie The Dead
what she died how what happened that's her mom oh
it makes me sad I really liked her character a lot
what what what what is this yeah what
is this is it real she is the world's
only Megalodon in captivity why
do you have that in captivity
okay so they have to study yet clearly
they didn't watch deep blue sea thanks
to you we have the ability to
go further than ever before
I'm all for what he just said but do we
have to have that in captivity no I mean
this is movie writing at its best for a
sequel they're like let's just have it be
there and then bad stuff happen who wants
to get a selfie with the man who fought a
Megalodon and lived to tell the tale we give
you ladies and gentlemen Jonas Taylor 18 ABS
yeah I really hope they cut to them training
the shark like uh kill you doing a whistle and
giving it fish he probably would be like one
of the most famous men in the world yeah why
why
oh with the with that suit I guess it's the Nano
yeah yeah I want to dive the trench no I'm almost
diving all the time at my age not the 25 000 feet
saying is too dangerous uh it's just a little
in Psychology they call that cognitive dissonance
in the real world they call it parenting
I like that description you're 14. exactly
I know every system on model one she's
been fixing ships since she was like five
minutes God it's gonna be like Tiki versus human
all over again except with a Megalodon you hear
what he just said he said is the experiment
do I taste good oh yeah I am all in protein
what you can't bet on a shark man that's a
bad company hey look who's back I'd like to
respectfully suggest that this is truly a
terrible idea mags and Humanity were never
meant to mix yeah he and I have a special bond
oh God every Sea World trainer Circa 2000 right
what are you doing oh I kind of want
to reach out and pet it too but also
I'm a little scared I think she's looking at us
she's clocking her dinner for later tonight yeah
seeing what's on the menu she's coming around
heart rate is up oh God yeah dude heart rate is
up good luck buddy she's not responding 200 meters
say bye bye it's too late
what's he gonna do
no did he just eat him oh my God yeah
what what
did you just shoot up because we didn't see
yeah he did something where he was pulling
to the side it was still a dumb idea in my
opinion you are taking bigger and bigger risks
each time you go out I guess we both know about
that the guy who jumped into the water with the
mag just said you're taking bigger risks yeah
just sand I think battling something he's
just trying to save the environment yeah I think
battling a few humans is not as big of a deal yeah
it does it's like we can
relate I guess yeah but not
um I mean the concept is interesting yeah
many depth that's a little scary foreign
I still love Jason Statham in this film
he just like he looks a little bored yeah
yeah but I still love him obviously
I'm still happy that he's here yeah
[Music] it's like I gotta battle
this damn my key is gonna Escape
my business
yeah I think you're right figuring out
his Escape what is he gonna Ram it I
mean you're probably strong
enough let's do it enough
that quickly you got out amazing why wouldn't
it be stronger I feel like those would be
reinforced a little bit better but yeah why
wouldn't it be like that's the strong oh my
goodness I figured it would take a couple of
rammings everyone let's get the show underwater
feet we are exploring area 19. so now they're
gonna be that's gonna be a conflict for her
because it's going to be a Megalodon
she grew up with because it was a baby
Megalodon and now they're gonna have to
battle it I guess ready for the drop guys
again I'm still always amazing this in
the first one the visuals are always
there yeah so good we're going on
a shark Adventure I'm still with
you what you said in the first one
I want to hear Under the Sea yeah
it's 11 over Mission spec IES
more like you're a mouth breather
uh oh did you sneak aboard uh oh Jonas oh crap
that's not good I see that you're angry but I
believe that this is a reasonable and can I just
say I did all kinds of stupid things when I was
14. oh my goodness really this is your 26th trench
die without incident Subs of electric predator
actually yeah she's smart enough she's like I
thought of everything we've got company [Music]
a MAG
gie he died flank speed
this was the perfect Trench Run
for you to sneak aboard yeah
impossible just got possible 500 meters
to the thermocline my teeth closing fast
cool be careful don't worry I'm
not gonna break the pretty toys
feel like you are it says warning Ah that's
so spooky but cool too she must
have followed our heat signature
that's great she must have escaped
how did that happen that's why you
don't have a pet shark proximity
alert Megs ah she's calling him
[Music] Dude Looks old and ready to
fight like has been through 17 Wars oh my
oh my goodness did this make anyone's ever say
terrifying we have to see what they're up to
and what about me well I thought we'd go if you do
not have any fear kid nah man she grew up with Mom
she's been around Megs her whole life see anything
dangerous back we're changing the mission profile
I do like that that girl's on her side because
I would be too I'd be like she's 14 whatever
let's explore we're gonna follow some giant sharks
to our unknown sector I'm with him I'm with him
yeah I don't think they should be following him
but I feel like maybe she's all right he's the
only one who has logic consent yeah I've
seen enough shark movies to know you don't
follow the where the sharks are but we need
to follow the movie tropes for the action
for entertainment purposes of course I want
them to but if it were me of course yeah I'm
not gonna have it your mom loves this place more
than anything I'm glad I finally get to see it
you're grounded for the rest of your life that's a
reasonable response is some instinctual Gathering
they're here to mate that's why haichi has
been acting strangely right well thanks
no way is that a wreck
that's not that [__] from the beginning
is it I don't think so I have more airlocks
who would even have the technology oh is what's
his nuts back from the office yeah he died in
the first movie yeah he died because he was the
money man yeah well mind is tough and steady oh
it's that the guy with the glasses and he said I
don't like him the party okay it's the competition
explosives
to get clear sorry guys what what just
don't do it see that's the difference oh yep
oh my God I'm gonna have to go through
oh my goodness I was gonna say that's
the difference between him and
Jonas like he did it maliciously
where Jonas had no choice to
do it in the first film right
yeah is that the bad ship
I hope so oh yeah we want
him to get in the bad guy yeah oh okay good it was
dude you're blowing up underneath
the ocean like what the f
well that's gonna let that's gonna
release them yeah there we go I mean
that's where where was it three Megs
under there yeah cheese and there
might be a birth soon they were mating
yeah well we gotta have a meg3 so ah
oh boy all right I thought you
said I'm not gonna hurt the toys
oh boy Whoa that is oh my
goodness are they gonna get buried
alive what if the Megalodon goes after the things
and breaks up the Rock and then they still live
how's that possible is it her uncle well
how long to fix it it's the control board
Mac there is no fixing it [Music] we're losing
air fast Rob the power through the heating cell
I like that they're not just putting
Jason Statham in there to fix it that
it's like the women fixing it and he
kind of hasn't had much to do but like
to the emergency dive suit
somewhere we're gonna need a ride up
that's going to be a problem it's not
going to be possible oh my goodness
we can't walk oh do they have those mecco suits
or whatever those suits have two hours here oh
see there you go it will go slow and steady
they'll hold it's three kilometers you'll
be defenseless out there I just want to see him
punched yeah this is what we got and this is what
we're gonna do yeah we're not just gonna die down
here this is too similar to that Titanic situation
that just recently happened yeah the filming
happened way before that but still it's kind
of meta yeah oh but they get weapons the radios
won't relate to the surface so we're going dark
I don't think the uncle would do that I don't
think it was I don't think it was the uncle I
was just like well why was he like let's push
down to go see all the sharks like I don't
think it's not him because it wouldn't make
sense one of those women on board or now or
do you think it was the woman with the glasses
or no maybe it was that guy who's on uh on the
other ship oh yeah maybe he knew where they
were and like was like no like or it could
have been the other guy that we didn't like
that blew up the other ship when he went to
the party he could have I don't know because we
didn't really see what he was doing at the party
don't know I feel like no one going down in these
two could have done it even though why would they
sabotage their own ship their own like safety
and going down you put your own life at in Risk
I hope that wasn't enough
foreshadowing oh nice nice light
hey
how is everyone so calm right now
it'd be like freaking out they're
ocean workers oh my god oh oh yep is it
gonna squish you [Music] no touching stuff
see this is why I wouldn't be calm for this
particular thing reason but it's so pretty down
there I understand but Megalodons are not pretty
when they're gonna eat you hungry that sub was
definitely sabotage yeah I think it's that guy
from the did the bombs but that's my guess when
the Personnel falls on the cooler for anything
suspect we're gonna get these sense of [__]
but we have to watch our own backs you're probably
right I don't know well did he die though did that
thing die did he get blown up and die it looked
like it but I don't know I feel like it was too
early in the film to get rid of the main building
that's not the yeah it would make sense that
they were like we don't want we built a thing we
never want them to discover our thing down there
I'd say he's the first one to go well yeah he's
gonna lose that oxygen before he even gets eaten
I say shark before oxygen
what was it uh we are we going with the Jaws
approach of not seeing if you just fell in
a hole Something's Happened to him I
know it oh boy there goes the helmet
we have to keep moving no we
don't we he's dead honey I understand but
what are you gonna go like search all over
the place also when it's that deep you would
just die I think immediately from the pressure
oh this is the main villain oh good he's still
alive yeah you say good I say bad action he's
gonna give us some action it's her oh geez
she's The Saboteur so I was half right yeah
you are there's still a kilometer to go
straight through that Valley and we don't
that's a good idea 65
oh God it's not like it honey I'd still
rather go from Suffocation than from
a Meg eat me after huh I got a little
thing keeps going in and out stalking us
yeah okay is this a Piranha movie now see a fish
just to show the fish I mean they running from
something though y'all maybe 400 meters [Music]
yeah it's so far
yeah just stop crying and panicking that moment
right there just reminded me of the first film
where she was talking DJ like dude calm down
just relax everybody might get to the station
they're coming over ah oh oh those ones
Oh They'll eat you up good wait what are
what are the are they piranha what are those
they're like dinosaur fish oh they'll get you oh
oh that's tough oh right those suits
punch really hard yeah break uh cement
okay
come on get it
nope this is not good I think the Megs
need to come and save them so many [Music]
oh they don't like the light yeah
basically calling for the Megs
to scare them off I don't know maybe
maybe haiji will come through for him
that reminds me of Jurassic Park
remember over here over here yeah [Music]
oh don't tell me he's sacrificing
himself you really want to die don't you
oh let's go come on run puppies ah [Music]
oh oh my goodness it's not too far you can
make it I don't think she's gonna make it
this is when you just go take me this
is yeah I was gonna say that's that's
a Trope and Meg where people
like to sacrifice themselves oh
wait did I couldn't see Diddy I don't know just
like we don't know what Jason and mailing like
no they didn't end up ah you've got to go we
don't have a place it's coming back around go go
come on We're not gonna make it
good
oh at least it's a quick death I mean that
would be so much pressure with an explosion
getting ready for Halloween already oh man
you better watch out not put your mouth in
that water there's a dead head exploded up
in there right yep yeah because it wasn't
depressurized when that happened yeah I'd be
like I'm gonna keep my helmet on for a minute
you read us uh I still don't understand what that
woman who's the villain is spending money on them
to build the underground thing that they don't
want them to find but also put in money with
Marwan like she's the money person hopefully
they will explain that nobody home run in this
it's not our friend we need to contact model one
ASAP you can handle it yeah yeah sure get it girl
what is this the demonic whatever it is you're
sending it up to the surface with these pods
mining crystals they're using superconductors
Aerospace and Quantum computing
this box along could be a billion dollars oh mine
in for fine gems you're alive I was going over the
video of when you went over that station before
looks like emergency escape paths oh they can use
those I bet you that lady's going to be like
how do you expect me to pay for Mar 1 without
me illegally mining Jewels at the bottom of the
ocean these are my designs how do they have this
it's a job think about who could get that stuff
in there you know figure it out on three three
come on Jason Statham could do that by
himself please mailing's gonna figure
it out she's gonna be like here you
go turn the key press it still I know
Jason Statham could still do that on his
own I don't buy it no it's really a good
thing she came along they really wouldn't
have figured that out close the hat on
it that wasn't me we need to talk handedly I
have full control of the station and I block
down this room oh she's working with the lady
three of our friends are dead because of you
it's the first Escape pod save me
Jonas in the heart why he's barely done
anything but give him a wink to be like fake it
or they can do a fake at like you
said yeah you should do it also too
easy [Music] he's gonna say he's got 18
ABS he'll survive we'll be back at work
in a week using your technology to take
whatever we want chewing up the scenery
yeah
teacher finish this
yes stupid ecosystem it's all about the money
if we could capture coming to the
surface mailing will figure it out
she knows computer stuff I'm telling you
if I were them I would have just told
them what they want to hear go back
and then you do what you do to them
5 30 60 seconds before he passes
out all right buddy he's gonna do it
all right now shut off the flooding mate
I will say even though I said he looked
bored in this film as an uh as an actor
he's really doing a good job filling the
surrogate father role like you really do
feel a connection between yeah not only
that but like the passage of time between films
that they've had with each other yeah I agree
foreign
that wasn't a Meg that was the other thing okay
oh boy I think it's been 30 seconds did you do it
oh he's about to pass out oh I think he did it
uh you did it right oh God yeah tough did he
get in there this is like an acid trip oh my
God let him out you don't you don't remember
me do you there's a million scumbags in
this world I saw they keep track of all
of them yes there we go let's get into it I
was gonna say like fighting a human being is
so like nonchalant for him after fighting
megalodons yeah it's like this is nothing
yeah buddy yeah
oh there we go this is how they get turned into
minerals the rocks yeah oh God I felt that one
nice
right at the oh the nick of time ooh come on
buddy you could do it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hit the red button hit it
okay I'm not a doctor but how
are you still getting up after
those metal shots to the face oh
are they gonna just disable the
risk cover the truth like she could
be repairing it right but not wait
the truth shall set you free or piss you
off we'll never make it past the Megs we
need the destruction let up the station
to Max without a tuck it and kill us
nothing we're fast enough are we doing the mag
thing of sacrificing or so what are we doing here
so it seems like they're having them
attack the baseball they ship out no
he's not oh no Jonas like waiting like
he didn't have to in the first movie
facing your demons of waiting not waiting
it's like hey waiting work this time it's
a hole in the thermal there oh yes oh
they're gonna be able to escape yeah
you will see that eventually I mean I'm a dumb
dumb but is there a way to fix the whole or no way
time what is that is that like a
like a octopus yeah well didn't we see one in
the first movie yeah I just forgot about it
how are you escaping oh smart and
how are you not in ultra pain from
the metal shots you took I don't want to
harm you but I do need you to come out of
[Music]
I love it I love it do it yes oh God no come on
really really no you did not that really hurts
yourself in the eye buddy you're smarter than that
I don't like that right pepper sprayed himself
right accident I just saw him go up with the taser
and I'm like I thought he pepper sprayed himself
accidentally what does it say um terrorist action
yeah good too I love peace too yeah oh did DJ
where did that come from I love it oh my God nice
oh my god oh
I'm not gonna lie that might have
been my favorite moment in both films
after the first film I'm taking karate lessons
or Kung Fu whatever whatever style of fighting
that was that was awesome I trained up
I learned how to fight I learned how to
swim and I'll never go anywhere without my
survival package yeah I'm glad you learned
how to train even though I don't know what
could that would have been with the oh wow
yeah I even made poison tip bullets just like Jaws
too yeah yeah wait poison tip bullets just oh yeah
yeah and Jaws to uh Roy shatter's character did
have he shot him into the ocean and then it was
a blue School of Bluefish and he scared the the he
scared the beach goers oh that gun's in your face
though dang it that was some unfortunate
[__] back there I love to show so much
that was great cool
DJ just sat on him I love that
are you okay it took uh some shots to the
face we need to lock this place down now as
he have no marks on him nothing though guys looks
like the Megs are here we've got a big problem
yeah yeah three of them it's from the
thermocline breach but you can relax this place
Meg proof I was also thinking
just with one little punch it's so easy we
paddle out slow no engines minimal motion
it won't look like food I still think we
look like food I just stay away from water
or find them and once you escape like after the
first movie too let's not bring them back alive
you do know how to draw this thing
right you guys oh yay you look like
food now dummies stop the engine right now
attractive mess I want to see him get it
at the shot take it
what do you want me to do fix it kill them
you're the most generic villains ever yeah we
have to find a way to warn people in case the
max move towards land there's nylon 60 clicks
sausage of us it's listed as inhabited for an
island where they say oh okay like fun party
people oh this does look fun oh I want to go
to fun Island it's about to be scary Island
but y'all need to comment and let me know a
fun Island really exists because I need to
go to there yeah and where it is too is it
is OMG and yes I know people Pippin is a
reference to the first Jaws movie Pippin
the dog I know I missed that reference
stay out of the water oh it is Pippin it's
Pippin yeah hey don't let pip in the water
please he survived the first film come on
get out of here Pippin knows the dog always knows
oh he's gonna okay oh we propose are we proposing
I know it's a nice ring though she's gonna say
yes put it on and get eaten by Meg immediately
I feel like that's about to happen oh
no find it it just dropped honey oh boy
you fall in the water yeah she went bye bye
bye Meg but nobody heard it apparently yeah
oh God it scares me oh my God
whoa really doing the whole Alfred hitchcocky
and just oh it's the octopus [Music]
they're like we're at fun Island
we're not getting off the beach
whoa what's happening here oh is it the
dinosaur lizards is it yeah it must be
you guys yeah it is are we gonna see
another Tyrannosaurus or is I wish
ah the noises oh my God I'd
be freaking out oh my goodness
whoa
yeah that is such a cool shot
though that shot that was amazing
is my the helicopter in my pull down sunny no
I want the helicopter shot oh yeah no it's not
why can't I get my helicopter shot this lady
she's gonna wander you are really dumb you
just told your helicopter pilot to get out of
the helicopter and go chat I can't I was like
really she's gonna get eaten by a lizard Dino
it's gonna be great yes she is you called it
[Music] that reminds me of uh Newman from
Seinfeld and uh oh my God they're going up
that was satisfying though that was good
I did not like her much unless she got it
in here emergency stuff really
I mean that is a good thing to have
in case of an emergency he ain't wrong
this stuff is as powerful as TNT
oh from those creature things lizard things
come on oh my God that one got me
let's go
oh my God girl really hey because all
of you together up against the wall
uh uh put those rappers down oh you'll do what
yeah but aren't they gonna get in
there with you with you guys too yeah
ah those things are [Music]
oh oh you just missed it oh man it's like
jousting you gotta You Gotta Get Right There
whoa okay now now do it
looks awesome damn that's cool
goodbye one down two to go
foreign
[Music]
oh yes nice we gotta go
oh God that reminds me of
the Velociraptors and Lost
World Jurassic Park when they run
through the grass gas we need that
that's filling up really quickly
that's smart if you can get up and fuel
or don't let it fill up y'all barely
got any oh boy oh no oh my gosh no
light them on fire oh they have a lighter on
them oh flare gun yeah they'll light them on fire
they're really good at improvising
no what why are you shooting at him when he's
going after a Megalodon my God this guy like
let him let him kill the Megalodon first and then
go ahead and take him out if you want words making
she is so brave
oh no the octopus the helicopter no Jason's
gonna have to get her I wanted the helicopter
oh but you're you're doing this is
not the helicopter I wanted to go down
no sacrificing
no not Cliff Curtis dang it did he
get off uh maybe he'll survive uh
whoa whoa damn
whoa damn that reminded me of Quint going falling
down the ship in the Orca and the first Jaws
dude you are so getting eaten and I cannot wait
yeah hand to hand man how many shots to the
face has this guy taken nothing hurts him
oh blood yep there you go uh oh
he's such a badass yeah you couldn't do it
that was cool what she's gonna
come back next scene and be fine
oh no traffic come on chop it
in the Box thing yeah whoa all right nice catch
holy to Molly that thing's huge
yeah but wasn't that supposed to
be for the Meg or one of them eggs
oh buddy [Music]
oh saved ya is it hygiene
oh oh whoa whoa no way is this like a
mega OCTA yeah I mean those aren't oh
I guess I got it ah yeah nope we thought you had
it but yeah I thought it did too damn it's like
that was my master from earlier in the film how
dare you if anyone will eat my master it's me
oh it's making noise oh
is he gonna cut it open with that I remember he
did that in the first oh nice get the blade going
I don't know how you picked that up but then again
you're Jason stake so I believe in you oh oh make
noise with it that's what Roy Scheider did in
Jaws too he was making noise as a distraction
I assume that's a shallow yeah I think
that's a shallows reference ah yes yes oh
that's that zombie eye going uh-oh oh nice
oh no you don't get him DJ right yeah DJ
is such a badass Nice Shot buddy no it's okay so
listen to me let's spread out he's gonna be like
no I trained her I got this no I feel like hygiene
might listen I don't know if it is her maybe she
would I mean do you think the shark did save him
from that squid octopus thing because I feel like
oh yeah see now she knows oh yeah
oh she's like it's okay I know you
oh I still don't trust it I don't
really either but maybe yeah
sometimes there's a situation and bad
things are happening and you just have
to get involved I'm proud of you good job
where are you what about haichi she's still
out there maybe pregnant ah preferably not
oh she's definitely pregnant it's looking
looks like Survival Island except for
what is this the shark nobody went over
there it's like we'll take any
amount of money to survive Island
oh man all right okay this one okay all right Meg
two the trench yeah I mean it was good it was fun
I didn't like it as much as the first one with
you on that yeah I mean I mean how what are your
first like what's your first thoughts okay well
just because we like to be positive around here
um I still think the strength because
for me the biggest strength of the
first film definitely fun in in that aspect
obviously turn your brain off type of film
um same thing here turn your brain off type of
film but I think the biggest strength of the first
film was like the relationship between Su Yen and
her daughter and then also Jason Statham coming in
like the bond ship that he has with uh the three
of them I really like the role that Jason Eve
again I know I made that comment that he kind of
looks bored in this film but I really do like that
surrogate father role that he takes up in the film
yeah with mailings yeah with mailing it was it was
really yeah thing sorry excuse me uh I really do
like it it was really sweet and Deering and like
I really did buy the the history in between films
that they had had and obviously uh with the uh the
encounter that they had from the first film like
I really did buy it and yeah it was really sweet
and I just enjoyed all their scenes all their
interactions I I love their chemistry the two
actors they really you know I couldn't take
my eyes off the screen whenever they were you
know on the screen together and uh I really did
feel invested when and scared for them when even
though I had a feeling they were gonna survive I
didn't think they were going to take her out in
the movie or Jason Statham either and I I always
felt like he had a good shot of surviving against
the shark or whoever he was facing but still I
always felt invested and and worried for them
and the stakes were high whenever those two are
on screen yeah and again staying on the positive
I love what they did with DJ in this film yeah
again I loved him in the first film he always had
the the logic in the sense like what are we doing
in this situation get out of the way whatever you
always had logic and sense and then again in this
film like getting like that one scene where he had
the fighting in the tremble where did that come
from comedic relief and that is great oh my God
we're I mean and then I still really love Cliff
Curtis as well he was he was a blast as well a
joy to watch so the chemistry between that and
I like the uncle too I thought he did a good
job I personally would have loved if they would
have kept suyen in this and even with the uncle
I still think they could have made it work again
I'm not a writer I don't know how you know wood
probably would have been tough to figure out a way
to find a way to do all those characters but still
yeah I really did like suyen from the first film
so I wish they would have found a way to do that
but I think the reason he probably likes sui and
wanted her back this movie didn't have as much
heart as the first one it lost the heart even
though like Jason and May Ying when they were
on screen they had a really great relationship
and that was really cute but we didn't get to
see any really much of the foundation being built
unless you're just remembering one yeah so I think
a lot of the heart was taken out versus in one I
was like I got close to crying when the dad died
and then uh you know and then they had to tell
May Ying about it in the first one it was just
sad people there was just a little more heart in
it where they had to bond over these like life
experience and be like we gotta find Megalodon
and also s-h-i-t is going down versus this one
there was still a lot of stuff going on and I
like to see the payoff with May Ying of being
like she's smart she was raised by her mom she
knows stuff like she's in there kind of saving
them like yeah they brought her along but I I felt
like the payoff with the with her and her new dad
I would have liked to see more of them kind of
in the beginning of maybe more of a relationship
so that the ending was even sweeter I don't know
exactly how they maybe could have done that with
um her and the uncle and Jason um but I do think
like that moment at the end when they're like
absolutely meaning they come together to tell
her you're still grounded is a way of the script
bringing it which could have had I think a better
payoff as like these are her new parents now but
it didn't give me as many of like the heart feels
as the first one for sure and I'm all about those
those like heart feels but this was still a
blast we got to see a mega octopus a bunch of
Megalodons and like use some cool cool stuff
I would also add my other one positive Pippin
oh yeah and Pippin survived that's also a positive
um for negative the fact that Mae Yang saved yet
again from the ocean Pippen's got to survive every
time that has to be a call back to each and every
one no for sure and uh like I said I I of course
forgot uh which I already mentioned during the
reaction but just in case it got cut out uh
Pippin was a reference to the first Jaws film
where Pippin the dog was uh in that film in the
shark off screen took out Pippin which the shirt
the dog did not survive sorry yeah well sorry
to all of us but um yeah no I'm glad that the
dog survived in both films good job by the writers
but uh bad job on the writers in my opinion with
the villains in this film I thought they were so
I actually did like even though he was a piece
of crap uh Rayne Wilson's character was funny in
the first film but made dumb decisions especially
going out where he you know got eaten by the shark
I thought he made a really dumb decision there but
there were stuff about him where I just found him
again he was hilarious and um I just found myself
relating to certain things about his character
he was a more fun Village it was definitely more
fun whereas the villains here I'm like they're so
generic and I'm like I can't wait to see them get
eaten totally 100 I mean I didn't really believe
her the main villain and then the blonde girl
that she hired yeah so was dating the Man villain
yeah all of those three villains I didn't really
believe that much not at all acting wise it seemed
like it might have been the direction I'm not sure
that it seemed very much like what are you doing
we're here to get the gems uh not that bad but
you get you get what I'm saying versus like when
Jason Statham delivers a line even though it may
be overly dramatic like whatever that one line
was like they're coming and get us I don't know
what it is but I always believe him versus those
three villains and maybe that was on purpose yes
that they felt uh very uh they didn't feel as
grounded it felt like when they would deliver
something it felt just like the payoff wasn't
really there but um I mean obviously we had to
have them there she's she's like I have a bunch
of dollars to build these these ships that go way
down but I'm not doing it for research I'm doing
it for Jim and again this is not like yeah and I'm
sure they're all competent actors I have not seen
any of those three and anything else no no yeah
yes I'm sure only just yes yeah yeah and I mean
could be Direction could be the writing of course
yeah and again this is more on the writing now
when it comes to the main uh woman villain like
why did you go go to the island first of all that
made no sense to me and then when you're about to
leave you hear a noise or something why did you
tell your helicopter pilot to go out and go and
check yeah get out yeah leave like I get it the
writers learn how to fly a helmet lady I mean I
get it that the writer's like well I have to come
up with a way to kill her off so but that's the
dumbest thing ever well they could have I mean the
little the the dinosaur lizards could have just
eaten both of them right away right because that
guy ran off yeah ever came back or you could have
had the shark just jump into the sky and rip it
oh yeah he's missing his shark with the helicopter
yeah you did it with the okay look thank you for
doing what the octopus but was with Cliff Curtis
and you know I would have rather it wasn't the
right helicopter it was the Wonder one he's gonna
be whining about it for the next month she's gonna
have to hear about it and so are you guys we don't
we mean it I'm just gonna be like block his number
We're not gonna talk or do a reaction for the next
month which is only going to be like she wears
my helicopter when she unblocks me she's gonna
text her are you ready to not talk about that or
do I have to block her are you over it yet buddy
because I feel like we need to get over it yeah
but overall look I I again I don't think I think
you said it best I don't think this had and again
the first one wasn't the greatest film ever it was
a fun time I just had more but it had more it for
sure had more heart than this but having said that
I still really enjoyed the the scenes between uh
and and uh Jonas yeah Jonas uh Jason say them I
still really enjoyed those scenes and I still
like the camaraderie and the chemistry between
Cliff Curtis DJ and even the uncle I thought he
did a really good job the actor who played him
um and the five of them I thought they all did
and even the uh I forgot the actress who played
the the character was she did a pretty good job
as well yeah I thought they all did it you know
the payoff of DJ learning a bunch of stuff like
I learned from the first one yeah I learned how
to learn hi and bring weapons and bring we didn't
get to see him use the the poison darts oh no no
he did did he he did yeah remember he he shot
at the the lizard thing oh he did okay yeah I
would have loved to have seen it on a Meg but he
did get to shoot he did get to shoot the lizard
you're right dragging whatever those things were
yeah and I like that he used the mirror thing to
call back to a bunch of films whatever but like
I just love how how he upped his game which was
super fun also his like roundhouse kick I was
like uh that looked awesome like no stun double
for you sir yeah no they weren't cutting they they
went wide shot and no cut I was like good for you
man but it was an awesome reveal that you wouldn't
expect it was like this is awesome like after the
even though you can't really apply those skills to
um Megalodon shark still it would make sense after
the events of the first film okay I gotta learn
stuff yeah I mean and you could with those poison
darts I don't know yeah for sure yeah uh also you
know a little disappointed we didn't get to see
the 18 ABS that might still be stuck on Jason's
stuff he's got him I mean it's not necessary but
a little bit just for a little bit come on now
Statham there's still time for something the
first one they'll do it in the third film they're
like we're only doing them on odd number films
don't worry oh really all right well well we know
that we know that other shark is still out there
and she's probably gonna give birth most likely
because they we saw a little scene there we're
amazing and you called that the whole thing
so we're gonna have more Megs out there which
is good I mean by that time make three I mean Mae
Ying is gonna be like a full-on teenager or maybe
a young adult who can drink who knows how long
it's gonna take but I'm gonna rate it out of ten
I would give this like I'd give it like a 6.5 I
was thinking six points like 6.5 because it was
still a lot of fun I love seeing them I mean who
doesn't the Megalodons when they're on screen and
Mal's just like eating all these people I mean I
don't want people to die in real life you guys get
what I mean it just looks it looks so awesome
yeah and yeah I would say probably 6.5 as well
okay yeah so there we go what was your favorite
part oh um I would say my favorite part was the
DJ reveal with his skills that was that was the
greatest moment ever yeah and surviving it's uh
those two yes I I I was gonna say I liked the cut
making saving pip and that was a lot of fun but
um DJ's reveal was great I don't know what
was my favorite part oh God you guys oh ah
um uh Under Pressure yeah I don't know I was gonna
say like when he went into the plane I was like
that was cool but that's at the top of the film
I would just say anytime the magazine something
I can't really think of a big thing from this one
I mean I asked you the question when the woman
the main woman villain gets you and that was so
satisfying I'll give you that one that was good
that was good I was glad to be whatever you know
I mean I feel like that's it my uh my my yeah 6.5
I liked it it's good the Meg is good it's always
good we always want to see Megalodon on screen
especially if Jason Statham is there just next
time maybe shows your 18 ABS again please sir
that's the problem with this film yeah man 18
absolutely not back still love me Ying I hope
she comes back for many many more and I mean you
guys can comment and tell us what you feel like
the juice is what's the juice that we miss what's
the stuff that we I don't know tell us what movie
we should watch next just tell us honestly what
life is I'm gonna be honest with you because
uh life it's like I sometimes I feel like that
shark who looked real rough like he's been through
18 mores I feel like that sometimes so like your
advice of being like do this thing I might take it
you know because we love you guys I think that's
it any last thoughts Andrew no just uh excited for
uh whatever we react to next yeah we love you so
much that end of the May o me too the trench bye
foreign